Traductor: Florencia Bracamonte
Revisor: Sebastian Betti
"Entre Uds. que me escuchan
y yo que les hablo,
lo único que podemos compartir
es el abismo que nos separa",
dijo alguna vez Georges Bataille,
un gran filósofo francés.
¿Qué quiere decir que lo único que
compartimos es el abismo que nos separa?
¿Que no tenemos nada
en común entre nosotros?
¿Que somos extraños?
Por ejemplo, ahora yo nada sé de Uds.,
y Uds. nada saben de mí.
Y, sin embargo, estamos aquí reunidos,
más de 4000 personas en este anfiteatro,
como hacían los griegos:
reunidos alrededor de un viejo rito,
el de la palabra compartida.
Nos reúne un rito humano,
"demasiado humano",
como diría Nietzsche,
el rito de la conversación.
Ese rito expresa, quizá,
el porqué de la filosofía,
el amor por la sabiduría, porque
solo sabemos que no sabemos nada,
como decía Sócrates.
Y nos reunimos para desandar ese camino,
que es el del no saber;
movidos por la ignorancia.
Por suerte somos ignorantes
y tenemos sed de conocimiento,
que es una sed compartida,
que es la sed que nos reúne hoy aquí.
Quizás no haya compartir
más genuino que esa sed,
que ese abismo que nos separa.
Quizás ese abismo no sea tal y tengamos
mucho más en común de lo que creíamos.
Quizás esa nada que tenemos en común
no sea otra cosa que la sed
de conocimiento que nos atraviesa.
Fue esa sed la que me llevó
a estudiar filosofía,
a transitar un camino
como el del conocimiento,
que siempre se mueve
entre la carencia del no saber
y la aparente plenitud
de lo que queremos alcanzar.
Entonces, me pregunto:
¿tenemos algo en común o lo único que
compartimos es el abismo que nos separa?
En el abismo que nos separa
compartimos algo, nuestra ignorancia
y algo incluso más profundo:
nada sabemos el uno del otro,
nada sabemos de los que nos precedieron,
nada sabemos incluso de nosotros mismos.
La historia, nuestra historia,
no es otra cosa que la búsqueda
de una única constante:
no estar solos.
Nacemos, vivimos y morimos ¿por qué no?
atravesados por una soledad constitutiva.
Sí, el mundo no es otra cosa que
"una inmensidad hecha de ausencia",
escribió alguna vez Dolina.
En medio de esa inmensidad,
estamos nosotros, solos,
pero queremos no estarlo.
Es justamente la soledad la que
nos permite saciar esa sed por conocer,
esa sed por explorar lo real.
Esa sed se sacia de a dos,
se sacia en comunidad,
como ocurre con la amistad,
como ocurre con el amor,
como ocurre con el conocimiento.
Es la ignorancia la que nos iguala
y es la potencia de la ignorancia
la que nos lleva a la búsqueda
de lo común: a no estar solos.
Es porque asumimos nuestra ignorancia
que estamos en esa búsqueda.
Y esta búsqueda nos humaniza,
esta búsqueda nos redime.
Esta búsqueda expresa una verdad profunda:
ese abismo que compartimos
es la profunda ignorancia
que todos los que estamos
hoy aquí compartimos.
Todos somos igual de ignorantes
en lo que respecta a los temas
realmente importantes.
¿O acaso alguien tiene
una respuesta definitiva para el amor?
¿Alguno de nosotros podría dar
una definición última de la amistad?
La filosofía, que nació allá lejos
y hace tiempo en Grecia,
quizás no tiene otra función,
imprescindible para nuestra vida en común,
que encontrarle un sentido a
una existencia atravesada por la soledad,
por el desamor;
en definitiva, por la ausencia.
Sabemos que el cuento no termina bien,
algo sabemos; el resto lo ignoramos.
¿Y qué ignoramos? Lo que vendrá.
Por suerte lo ignoramos
y esa ignorancia compartida
es quizá lo único que podemos compartir
por eso debemos hacer
de la carencia una virtud;
y de la ausencia, una positividad.
No debemos tener miedo de revelar
nuestra aparente ausencia de conocimiento.
Digo "aparente" porque
la consciencia de nuestra ignorancia
es un gesto de verdadera
y profunda sabiduría.
No debemos temer preguntar una y otra vez
si hay algo que no entendemos.
Entonces, si algo nos iguala
profundamente como seres humanos,
eso que nos iguala es la ignorancia.
La ignorancia nos iguala
de manera absoluta.
de manera radical.
Y esa igualdad, que es la ignorancia,
es el motor de nuestro conocimiento,
es el motor de nuestro desarrollo;
es aquello que nos permite,
a partir de un encuentro como este,
a partir de la experiencia comunitaria
del estudio, de la investigación,
correr el horizonte de lo real,
volvernos, en definitiva,
mejores personas.
Por eso, la experiencia del conocimiento
es una experiencia que nos humaniza,
que nos acerca.
Si la filosofía tiene
todavía hoy alguna función,
será la de enseñarnos a medirnos
con el tamaño de nuestra ignorancia.
Porque, como dice un amigo,
cuando el juego termina, el rey y el peón
vuelven al mismo cajón.
Entonces, juguemos mientras podamos,
que nuestra ignorancia y
nuestro tiempo presente así lo requieren.
Juguemos hoy aquí reunidos,
intentemos que este juego,
entonces, transforme nuestras vidas.
Pues, lo único que compartimos
es el abismo que... ¿nos separa?
(Aplausos)